the leveling up secretary told me in the
last hour that this was going to be a
game changer the government says this
fiscal event as they're calling it will
ignite growth so what do you make of it
well I think growth is the right
question because growth has been uh
extremely anemic under the conservative
party for the last 12 years it's been a
lot lower than was the labor rate of
growth and what they are trying to do is
to get back to something like the rates
of growth that the country enjoyed
during the labor years but the way that
they're doing this
is to run a huge risk with the public
finances by putting all of this on
borrowing and Simon Clark who was on
your program was issuing dossiers just a
few months ago about the labor party's
opposition to the National Insurance
rise saying this was the most
irresponsible thing since Kingdom Come
and it was going to result in a huge
black hole in the rivers would run red
and it would all be terrible here we are
a few months later with them agreeing
with us on that but going a lot further
and taking a big risk with uh public
borrowing at a time when the bank of
England is already raising interest
rates on mortgage rates well you say
it's it's a risk with borrowing but the
government says these plans will
stimulate growth and so there won't be a
problem
it's a it's a good question to see not
only what are you borrowing but what are
you going to do with it what are you
going to buy with it and actually at the
heart of this there isn't a plan to
create the kind of economic growth that
we need for example through uh a real
drive for The Greener transitioning
energy that we need to see an investment
in the skills and productivity capacity
of our Workforce reforms to business
rates which are raised with us
urgently by businesses of all kinds and
the institutional stability that we need
to see rather than a tug of war with the
bank of England the silencing of the obr
and so on so what they're doing is
borrowing for a return to trickle down
the idea that if only we unleash the
animal spirits and make those who are
already wealthy even wealthier then the
benefits will trickle down to the rest
of us that's an idea which was tried
before in the 1980s it didn't work so we
do need growth but we need growth that
everybody can take part in that
everybody can feel the benefit of and
from what's being trailed about today
that doesn't look like the outcome of
the plans that the chancellor will
announce well yes and Liz truss has
addressed this issue hasn't she she says
she's comfortable with the fact that the
rich May benefit a bit more from from
some of the tax cuts for example
scrapping the rise in National Insurance
she says they pay more tax to begin with
and ultimately not introducing that tax
rise I mean they'll spend more also
companies will expand with lower taxes
as well and ultimately everyone will
benefit well if you take cooperation tax
for example uh they want to keep
cooperation tax where it is right now
it's been the lowest in the G7 for many
years but we've also got the lowest
investment in the G7 in terms of
business so it hasn't produced the
benefits that we've seen they're trying
to sell today as some Brave New World
but actually after 12 years of failure
to deliver economic growth I think the
country is tiring of the idea that what
we need is to change the conservative
prime minister every two years that that
person will tell us all the policies
pursued up until now have been wrong and
a mistake and that suddenly there the
change that the country needs it's an
idea that's wearing thin and today feels
more like the last through the dice Than
A Brave New World on economic growth
so you you say you're worried about the
levels of borrowing but are you
comfortable with the tax cut
National Insurance for example we always
said that was a bad idea to impose a
National Insurance rise on working
people in the middle of a cost of living
crisis as I said we were furiously
attacked by that so we agree with that
part but on the rest of this we think
that it does run at risk to borrow for
broader tax cuts across the board every
country borrows money but if you're
going to borrow money there is an
important distinction between borrowing
for tax cuts or borrowing for
sustainable investment that might
actually improve your rate of growth in
the long term on things like
infrastructure and skills and cleaner
energy those are investments that we
could get a good return from and we
think that's where the investment effort
should go
right so what is Labor's plan for growth
then well the Energy's got to be at the
heart of it uh we've seen our
vulnerability over uh over the last year
so we would for example uh double uh
onshore Wind by 2030 we would triple the
amount of energy we get from solar power
we would bring forward new nuclear we'd
also change business rates to help
stimulate businesses we would guarantee
the institutional stability that the
conservatives have been so reckless with
and we'd also make sure that we're
investing in the skills and productive
capacity of the workforce and that seems
to be entirely missing from the plan
that's going to be announced today
we heard from the leveling up secretary
saying that Europe is in a pattern of
stagnation and we can't afford to be
part of that something radical needs to
happen doesn't it the government say
that's exactly what they're planning
his government has presided all those
stagnation we've had a far lower
they say they've got a new plan there's
a break with the past they always say
they've got a new plan this is the
seventh economic growth plan in the last
10 years it's the seventh plan to to do
what they say they're going to do from
the same government it's not a new
government they've been in power for 12
years the minister you just interviewed
served in the last cabinet the prime
minister is I think the longest serving
cabinet minister
of all of them and the chancellor is
also a long-serving cabinet minister too
I'm afraid it's wearing thin to say that
the seventh plan is going to be better
than the other six there is a pattern of
stagnation there's no point in blaming
Europe for it we've had a pattern of
stagnation on economic growth in this
country which has been presided over by
the conservatives and that's why they
are not the change that the country
needs you talked about the silencing of
the obr
um the obr often when there's a where
then there's a budget will produce an
analysis won't they of what it means for
the economy and how much it's going to
cost when I spoke to Simon Clark he said
it wasn't about silencing them he said
there wasn't enough time to pull
together a report or what do you make of
that honestly I think that's nonsense
um the what are they frightened of the
lbr are under a statutory duty to
produce a report uh twice a year we're
not today's event isn't termed our
budget but to be honest the measures in
it are as big as any budget may be
bigger so it is perfectly right that the
obr should have produced a report one
has to
assume that the government are
frightened of something that might have
been in that but there's a more
important point about this this point
about institutional stability
it's not just about the lbr it's about
flip-flops on policy this is the third
change in National Insurance in six
months that's been announced yesterday
we've got a tug of war with the bank of
England where they've had to issue a
warning to the government yesterday that
having raised interest rates by half a
percent they will return and do more in
November depending on what's announced
today and then you've got the firing of
the permanent secretary at the treasury
if you take all these things together
they do not send out a message of
confidence and stability to investors
and when you're borrowing as much as
this government is to fund tax cuts you
need that confidence from investors
they've been Reckless with this they
used to style themselves as the party of
sound money I don't think after today
they're going to be able to do that